what happened before that
well we don't know so this is where it
gets into a lot of speculation and
let's go i mean let's go there okay sure
so you know
nobody can prove that right what
happened before
t equals zero and whether there are
other universes out there
i like to say that these are sort of on
the boundaries of science
they're not just ideas that we wake up
at three in the morning to go to the
bathroom and say oh well let's think
about what happened before the big bang
or let there be a multiplicity of
universes
in other words we have real testable
physics
that we can use to draw certain
conclusions
that are plausibility arguments based on
what we know
now admittedly they're not really direct
tests of these hypotheses
that's why i call them hypotheses
they're they're not really elevated to
a theory because a theory in science is
really something that has a lot of
experimental or observational support
behind it so
they're they're hypotheses but they're
they're not unreasonable hypotheses
based on what you know about general
relativity and quantum physics okay
and they may have indirect tests in that
if you adopt this hypothesis then there
might be
a bunch of things you expect of the
universe and lo and behold that's what
we measure
but we're not actually measuring
anything
at t less than zero or we're not
actually
measuring the presence of another
universe in this multiverse
and yet there are these indirect ideas
that stem forth
so it's hard to prove uniqueness and
it's hard to completely convince oneself
that
a certain hypothesis must be true
but you know the more and more tests you
have that it satisfies let's say there
are 50 predictions it makes and
49 of them are in are are things that
you can
measure and then the 50th one is the one
where you
you want to measure the actual existence
of that other universe or
what happened before t equals zero and
you can't do that
but but you've satisfied 49 of the other
testable predictions and so that's
science
right now a conventional condensed
matter physicist or someone who deals
with real data in the laboratory might
say oh you cosmologists you know that's
not really science
because it's not directly testable but i
would say it's sort of testable
but but it's not completely testable and
so it's at the boundary but it's not
like we're coming up with these crazy
ideas
among them quantum fluctuations out of
nothing and then inflating into a
universe with
you might say well you created a giant
amount of energy but in fact
this quantum fluctuation out of nothing
you know in a quantum way
violates the conservation of energy but
you know who cares that was a
classical law anyway and then an
inflating universe
maintains whatever energy it had be it
zero or some infinitesimal amount
in a sense the stuff of the universe has
a positive energy
but there's a negative gravitational
energy associated with it
it's like i drop an apple i got kinetic
energy energy of motion out of that but
i did work on it to bring it to that
height
so by going down and gaining energy of
motion
positive one two three four five units
of kinetic energy
it's also gaining or losing depending on
when how you wanna think of it
negative one two three four five units
of potential energy
so the total energy remains the same an
inflating universe
can do that or other physicists say that
energy isn't conserved in general
relativity
that's another way out of creating a
universe out of nothing you know
but the point is that this is all based
on
reasonably well tested physics and
although these extrapolations
seem kind of outrageous at first they're
not completely outrageous they're
they're within the realm of what we call
science already and maybe some
young whippersnapper will be able to
figure out a way to directly test what
happened before
t equals zero or to test for the
presence of these other
universes but right now we don't have a
way of doing that
you